all right well I'm back for the video
today I'm going to do something a little
bit different I'm going to actually test
something on myself to prove that it's
completely harmless today I'll be eating
pure gluten but I bought this from a
chemistry company last week it says
gluten on there but yeah this is a pure
gluten 99% pure sea gluten is just a
protein it's found in bread and it's a
storage protein it's there's nothing bad
about it I don't see why people are so
afraid you know they're on the
gluten-free diet and gluten-free this
and gluten-free beer and glutens fine -
I'll prove it it smells like bread like
flour basically surprise surprised that
there is pure gluten as you can tell
can't really see but maybe if I come
back a bit yeah
see that's what pure gluten looks like
looks like just brown flour so bottoms
up hmm it's very dry very sticky tastes
like like flour
yeah like bread but as you can see I'm
fine there's no problems gluten there's
nothing bad about it so what is gluten
gluten excuse me
gluten is a storage protein that's found
in grass strains of plants we're talking
like wheat barley rye excuse me
not totally dry so yeah is it hot in
here is it this is me no hmm I know why
I keep coughing
but um lutein is perfectly uh it's safe
it's a natural perfectly safe to eat
this is for science just you can do this
science well I'm no throw Alden I'm just
gonna give them a call and make sure
this is actually safe to eat maybe it's
maybe it's it they got it wrong maybe
it's not gluten maybe it's um
like arsenic or something yeah hi um I
bought pure gluten from your company
last week but I did have a spoonful of
it is that uh-huh okay uh could I have a
script please is the are the walls green
to anyone else like this is green right
I got the script I'm gonna finish the
video I'm gonna go to the hospital
okay so gluten as you know is a storage
protein made of gluten made of prole
amine and glutamate amino acids it's
found in wheat and barley and rye grass
strains what else here
now obviously that won't happen if you
eat pure gluten and more importantly it
won't happen to me because I don't have
celiac disease but what if someone with
celiac disease were to eat pure gluten
well that would be bad
celiac disease is an autoimmune
condition where an individual's body is
intolerant of gluten a protein found in
wheat products as a result the gluten
triggers a response in the body that
makes the immune system attack cells
that line the intestines these cells are
specifically called inteiro sites and
are responsible for absorbing nutrients
into the bloodstream here's how celiac
disease works once gluten is consumed
and in the intestines it binds to the CX
cf3 receptor on the surface of entero
sites this binding signals the
enterocyte cell to release a protein
called zon Yulin which then binds to
receptors on inteiro sites
Wednes on you and binds it causes the
space between the cells to widen the
gluten protein then moves for this
opening into the intestinal space behind
the entero sites called the lamina
propria obviously gluten isn't supposed
to be here so this causes irritation to
the entero sites making them release a
second protein called interleukin 15
which draws immune cells to the site
okay right here is where celiac disease
goes from a laughing matter of haha you
can't eat bread - oh wow that's really
bad can I make you some hot cocoa the
signaling protein interleukin 15 isn't
supposed to be released due to gluten
being present instead it only gets
released naturally when a cell becomes
infected with a virus basically it goes
like this
step one virus infects the cell step 2
virus multiplies inside the cell and
step three virus spreads to the next
cell rinse and repeat in order to
prevent or at least slow down viral
infection in fact its cells have a
built-in mechanism where they release a
signaling molecule to alert immune cells
to kill them before the virus spreads
but with celiac disease this
precautionary mechanism is broken and is
activated by gluten instead this attack
on entero sites results in abdominal
pain chronic and foul-smelling diarrhea
loss of bone density and the biggest
problem reduce absorption of nutrients
the role of entero sites in your
intestine is to absorb nutrients from
your diet such
Minerals ions sugars amino acids and
vitamins when the entero sites become
damaged the villi which are the rug leg
extensions on the surface become
shortened or practically non-existent
this prevents them from absorbing
important nutrients also with less
absorption the individual is prone to
developing lactose intolerance
since the lactose sugars and the dairy
products aren't being absorbed into the
bloodstream they remain in the gut where
they're metabolized into lactic acid by
bacteria in your colon all of this is
the result of wheat flour containing
gluten on average wheat flour has a
gluten content of 13% what happens when
the individual eats 100% gluten why is
this video so long just go to this time
if you want to see your question
answered you know I never understood why
people do this there's a three-minute
long set up prior to the answer for a
reason it's like getting an answer to a
math question without doing the work I
mean how else are you going to learn
anything
hey wait weren't you in my chem class in
college yeah did you pass no I dropped
out of college Oh hmm awkward
anyways this is what happens when
someone with celiac disease eats 100%
gluten I live in a van well firstly with
that much gluten exposed to the
intestines all of these symptoms would
be drastically increased the intense
inflammation of the gut would completely
disrupt normal digestion inflammation in
your intestines is what causes diarrhea
and with this much gluten and
inflammation everything in your gut
would pretty much be nothing but liquid
diarrhea like the stuff in this blender
yeah that's a pretty good visual
secondly the inflammation in the gut
would be incredibly painful
in fact there'd be so much inflammation
and damage that you may develop ulcers
in your intestines finally the degree of
the immune response would be detrimental
the amount of signaling proteins immune
cells and damage to the site could put
the body into a state of shock as a
result there would be massive amounts of
histamine release a drop in blood
pressure as well as tachycardia
dizziness and fever the inflammation
would be so widespread that neighboring
organs may become stressed causing them
to release their own signaling proteins
thereby triggering a domino effect it's
unlikely that the person would die
though it would depend on their present
condition one thing for sure is the
intestinal damage would be very severe
and as always I'd like to take a second
to thank my very generous patrons who
helped support this and future videos
and now for a well deserved update on
the status of my old videos so as you
may or may not know I had to take down
about 95% of my content because it was
not fitting in to terms of fair use or
copyright and that's my fault
however as we speak I am working on the
videos right now and it is taking longer
than I expected so I can't give a date
or a timeline of when I'll be posting
but I'll try to post about 2 to 3 per
month and that may that may go up or
down so but more importantly I'd like to
personally thank my patrons as well as
my youtube subscribers that have stayed
with questions for science just to have
you guys here commenting all the
positive thoughts is a big help and I
really need it um a couple of days after
I took down my content I saw that I
started to lose some YouTube subscribers
and
it was pretty demoralizing however it is
bittersweet because though I did lose
some subscribers I did gain some patrons
and the patrons are what helped fund
questions for science and helped make
better content so though I did lose some
subscribers I'll be making better
material and for that I just want to
thank you all so much both the old and
the new patrons Thank You Constantino
Thank You Daniel Thank You Derek Thank
You Francisco Thank You Curtis Scott fan
Thank You Kuro Thank You Lydia Thank You
Marc Thank You Marcus and Thank You
Shannon and also to my youtube
subscribers who stayed with questions
for science thank you all so much thank
you for watching and stay tuned